winter is coming in the deader restless
East watch season 7 episode 5 reminder I
do not do spoiler free reviews for this
show anymore so let's get right to it a
bit of a slower episode following the
definitely be very rousing action scene
we got at the end of the previous one
and normally I'd complain about that the
show having kind of peaked and now
dipping except it didn't bother me as
much this time as it would normally I
think that has to do with the fact that
even though this was a very set up kind
of episode for what's going to be the
last two episodes of the season it
worked for me because the stuff that
they were setting up was not stuff that
I would have necessarily called in
advance like the whole idea that this
team has got to go up north of the walls
to try and capture a single white to
show - seriously to get her support I
wouldn't call that so that so setting
that up it was interesting watching
those pieces get moved into that
position normally set up episodes just
feel like very and not like we always
know it's coming but it feels like okay
you're doing this because you have to
because if you don't do this you skip a
step but it's going where we know it's
going in this case is not it was setting
up stuff that was not stuff I called in
advance that said I did call exactly how
this episode was going to start with
bran driving Jamie out of the water
I love bran so much and I think it's
probably not foreshadowing with his line
- Jamie no no one gets to kill you
except me
but I love that line I thought that was
great from bran that just felt
absolutely perfect
the other character who came pretty
close to stealing the show was Davos I
loved him sort of landing in King's
Landing first of all I lovely found
gantry we finally hit resolution on get
rid I love that Davos his line was oh I
guess you're not still rowing and that
was the last thing we saw him do in
season 2 so I that was a cute fun nod
and I like seeing demos you know bribe
the guards and work just watch him would
sort of work that magic and work that
charm because you know we've gotten
little hints here and there about what
his life was like as a smuggler before
he you know sort of found a
odd and it's it's just fun to realize
man he was really good at fast surge
auras back he's now regained his
position with Daenerys sort of and he's
been sent off on mission and I still
don't know if it was worth it or not I'm
still holding reservation there I mean
let me put it this way their reunion was
nowhere nearly as touching as their
departure had been so right now him
coming back is it's accumulating a debt
that they need to pay off because if
they don't I'm just going to throw my
hands up and go we didn't need him to
come back but we'll see where that goes
man Sam has it rough he's really really
trying to feel bad for him that said God
how painful was a moment with Gilly
reading and you know she's she's reading
something that is so important and Sam
just doesn't isn't paying attention and
it's so it's so hard because that's so
unlike him he's just too frustrated in
that moment although you know with
somebody devoted you know giving us all
that key information I think we should
be lucky that the finger of God didn't
come down and smote her mid-sentence the
way this show tends to go sometimes I
want to circle back on to Tyrion I think
he's really starting to second-guess his
allegiance with Daenerys I think he
probably still does believe that she is
the best option of what's out there
right now but boy you can you can see it
especially with his interaction with
Varys who was also great this episode
just it's weighing on him like what did
I sign up for Who am I backing Who am I
helping and the show is doing a pretty
good job of laying out the reasons why
Daenerys getting what she wants may not
be a good thing in a way that doesn't
betray the character because they would
have been very easy to like have her
start to really gain momentum and like
just the power of her officers like no
she's acting in a way completely
consistent with how we've seen her act
it's just that up until recently she was
you know having this attitude against a
city of slavers and you know these
people who we as an audience have no
investment in but now she's in Westeros
and she's dealing with people who I mean
maybe we didn't like I mean she burned
you know Sam's dad and his son who we
only just met but
this is a world that we've seen people
struggle over we know how this world
works better and we kind of as an
audience have more investment in it and
the people in it even if we don't know
the specific individuals so watching her
steamroll these people the same way that
she did with a place like slavers Bay
it's starting to sink in oh she's not
adjusting she's not tweaking her
approach because she's now in Westeros
oh dear and I think it's I personally
feel they're doing a good job of laying
those doubts for Tyrion and sort of by
proxy for the audience about what is it
we want to have happen it's a tougher
call than it appeared at first
especially with seriously laying as low
issues right now she's not stirring up
all that much ground but she is gonna
have another kid then okay I'm not even
entirely sure what to make of that one I
suppose it does rule out my earlier call
that Jamie was going to be the one to
kill her I think if she's carrying his
kid that's definitely not going to
happen and of course we've got little
finger stirring up crap in Winterfell
man this guy plans long term or I don't
know if his body plans long term he he
knows what - hang on - he knows was
probably going to be helpful later I
mean I'm glad he's around he's
aggravating in a really thrilling way
but oh it's gonna be so good to see him
get his because he needs to so I suppose
the big thing sort of left to do because
like I said though this was largely a
set up episode there was some nice
little moment some nice little reveals
but I personally didn't feel that there
was a big hub but you know a lot of good
moments I like the dragon facing down
Jon and all of that but I think the last
thing to talk about is this team headed
north of the wall what's going to go on
there well first of all I tried to
figure out okay who's going to die
there's no way that they're all coming
back and when I started to think about
that I actually stopped that thought
process partway through although for the
record I expect at least one of the
brothers without banners to die if not
both of them the rest of the ones it's a
tougher call for me but here's here's
what I want to see I want to see
something unusual happen either to the
members of this party or in terms of the
behavior of the whites or the White
Walkers
themselves in regards to the fact that
two of the members of this party have
died and come back to life and I would
be kind of disappointed if the fact that
they are effectively Walking Dead men
but are not like the army of the Dead I
will be disappointed that does not
factor in somehow cuz but you you said
two guys two guys up there who have died
and come back one of them repeatedly and
they're going up against you know and
dealing dealing with these things that
raise the dead like this has to come up
that I don't know how I don't know how
it's going to factor I don't know if the
if the white walkers are going to just
react weirdly weirdly towards them I
don't know if they're like Garfield Oh
to start you know to possibly serve the
the night's king I don't know but
something there's there's something
there's got to be something to this oh
and I think tormund Giantsbane might not
make it back either which would be a
real shame for me because I like him a
lot I would say kendrys disposal except
we don't we just got him back it would
seem weird to bring him back just to
have him die if either him or Jorah die
they gotta go out in a semi spectacular
fashion because in both cases they just
brought him back and it would be dumb to
have him back just to die if they don't
do something with it
Gendry swinging that hammer I like that
I love a good Warhammer so I think
that's about it that's my thoughts on
the episode it was good it was it it was
a less intense than the last episode but
I like what its setting up my life what
its building I like I'm really excited
for the next episode and I did actually
enjoy this one in and of itself as well
so solid stuff what were your thoughts
on it whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
or the punch like the girl podcast both
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]